Hallo, guten Abend. Ich heiße Hüseyin Czellik. Ich bin der DSH-Habend der Erste auf dieser Station.
Bevor wir über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, bräuchte ich ein paar allgemeine Informationen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Alexander Baumann.
Alexander Baumann. Könnten Sie langsam bestavieren?
Alexander schreibt sich A, L, E, X, A, N, D, E, R und Baumann B, A, U, M, A, N, N Baumann.
Herr Baumann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Am 14. März 1962.
1962? Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,79 m.
79. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 83 kg.
83. Okay.
Was für Sie ist zu uns?
Ich habe ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen seit, ja, wir haben jetzt morgens, also seit ungefähr 12 Stunden, habe ich ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen.
Wie weit sind Sie?
Wo genau haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Also, die sind mehr so im Unterbauch, mehr auf der rechten Seite und in der Mitte, Mitte und Unterbauch rechts.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen plöstisch aufgetreten oder langsam?
Ja, sie sind relativ plötzlich aufgetreten.
Plöstlich?
Ja, sie sind halb von einer halben Stunde. Also ging es ganz schnell dann sehr intensiv los.
Okay. Sind die Schmerzen im Lauf der Seite gewandert?
Nein, sie sind eigentlich immer so rechts im Unterbauch, da unten, hauptsächlich.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei der 1 sehr leicht und sehr stark...
Ja, ich würde sagen zwischen 5 und 7, weil der Schmerz ist nicht immer gleich stark.
Manchmal kommt so eine Welle, dann ist er ganz stark und dann dauert es ungefähr eine halbe Minute, Minute, dann wird es wieder etwas weniger.
Und dann kommt er wieder der Schmerz.
Okay. Können wir Kraftart sagen oder?
Ja, ich wellen für mich.
Wellen für mich.
Sind sie sich übergeben?
Mir ist jetzt seit einiger Zeit, einigen Stunden ist mir zunehmend übel und ich habe auch 2 Mal erbrochen.
Wie sieht das Erbrochen aus?
Das ist so schleimig, gelblich, wässrig.
Keine Blutung?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen.
Haben Sie im länden Bereich Schmerzen?
Was meinen Sie mit länden Bereich?
Rückenschmerzen?
Nein, Rückenschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie beim Wasserlassen Probleme?
Nein, Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung, ich muss immer in der Nacht 1-2 Mal auf Toilette, aber das schon seit einigen Jahren.
Aber das macht mir keine Probleme, das hat sich nicht verändert jetzt.
Okay.
Regelmäßig auch beim Urologen zur Förderuntersuchung, beim letzten Mal hat der Urologe gemeint, ich hätte an der Leiste eine weiche Leiste, eine leichte Vorwölbung.
Und er sagt, eventuell wird das ein leistend Bruch.
Das muss man beobachten, sagt er.
Wurden Sie nicht operiert?
Bis jetzt nicht.
Auf der linken Seite?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, gar nicht Stuhlgang habe.
Normalerweise habe ich 2-mal am Tag Stuhlgang, aber jetzt in den letzten Stunden habe ich gar keinen Stuhlrank.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie im Leistenbereich Wölungen?
Also der Urologe hat das festgestellt, er hat gesagt, da ist eine weiche Stelle in der Leiste.
Und er sagt, da kann eventuell ein Bruch entstehen.
Das muss man beobachten, sagt er.
Ich habe jetzt aber nicht getastet oder gefühlt.
Aber ich habe auch in dem Bereich etwas Schmerzen, da im rechten Unterbauch.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, aber seitdem ich jetzt die Schmerzen habe, die letzte Nacht habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten oder Atemnot?
Nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Heißstraßen, Herzklopfen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Vorerkrankungen?
Sie meinen andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, andere Erkrankungen.
Ich habe seit ungefähr zehn Jahren hoher Blutdruck bekannt.
Ja.
Dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Was nehmen Sie da gegen?
Ich nehme einmal Bisoprolol.
Ja.
Morgenstablette und abends eine halbe Tablette.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich noch Ramipril.
Ja.
Und dann nehme ich noch Ramipril.
Eine Tablette morgens, eine abends.
Wie viel, wie ist die Dosierung?
Ramipril steht fünf dahinter.
Und bei Bisoprolol auch fünf.
Auch fünf, okay.
Und dann nehme ich noch Alupurinol.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette, weil ich hohe Harnsäurewerte habe.
Und ich hatte auch schon zweimal ein Gichtanfall.
Im Seel?
Ja, im großen Segelenk.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Wann hatten Sie...
Das war so, der letzte war vor zwei Jahren.
Und der andere war, glaube ich, vor drei Jahren.
Vor drei Jahren, okay.
Haben Sie andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, nur diese Ramipril, Bisoprolol und...
Alupirinol.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind.
Da war ich zehn Jahre alt, da wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Ja.
Und dann hatte ich im Alter von 25 Jahren einen Oberschenkelbruch rechts.
Da hatte ich einen Motorradunfall.
Und da wurde das mit einem Nagel...
wurde ein Nagel reingebaut in den Oberschenkel.
Das wurde operiert.
Ich wurde gut...
dann wegen Akustik. Könnten Sie noch mal sagen...
Der Oberschenkel wurde...
Damals hieß es genagelt.
Ein Nagel wurde in den Oberschenkel eingeführt,
um das zu stabilisieren, den Bruch.
Okay.
Mit 25 Jahre, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sie können allegieren?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ähm, ich trinke vielleicht zwei Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Droge?
Nein.
Sind Ihre Familien irgendwelche Vorherkrankungen bekannt?
Mein Vater, der ist im Alter von 82 Jahren verstorben.
Damals hieß es, er hatte Herzschwäche.
Ja.
Die Mutter, die lebt noch, die ist 84...
Nein, die Mutter, die hatte mit 59 Jahren Darmkrebs.
Die Mutter wurde da operiert und hatte auch Asthma
und ist dann beim Alter mit 84 Jahren verstorben.
Also mit 59 Jahren hatte sie Darmkrebs, ja.
Okay.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder.
Ja.
Der ist 63 Jahre alt, 64 Jahre alt.
Er hatte vor zwei Jahren Darmkrebs und ist operiert worden.
Und es geht ihm jetzt gut.
Welche Operation hatte Ihr Bruder?
Der wurde wegen Darmkrebs operiert.
Ja, da wurde ein Stück des Darmes entfernt.
Okay.
Mutter auch?
Ähm, weil der Mutter wurde auch ein Stück vom Darm entfernt, ja.
Wann hatte die Bruder die Operation?
Vor zwei Jahren.
Vor zwei Jahren, okay.
Okay.
Herr Baumann, was machen Sie die Beruflich?
Ich bin Taxifahrer.
Gut.
Okay.
Sind Sie per-heiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und lebe mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Gut.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 28 Jahre und 30 Jahre alt.
Die sind gesund, aber die wohnen nicht mehr bei uns.
Okay.
Ich habe eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Was kann ich haben?
Das macht mir jetzt schon Sorgen.
Was habe ich noch nie gehabt?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht genau sagen, aber wir müssen ein paar
Untersuchungen durchführen.
Danach muss ich Blut abnehmen und dann ein Bauch
durchführen.
Dann kann ich Ihnen genau sagen, aber ich würde Ihnen sagen,
können Sie nicht bleiben?
Ja, kann ich.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt ein paar Minuten Zeit, sich vorzubereiten,
die Fachsprache zu bemühen, also Patientensprache.
Da war noch eine Frage, sehe ich da im Chat zum Gewicht.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit zu oder abgenommen?
Ja, eine wichtige Frage.
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht.
Mein Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Und vielleicht noch eine Frage oder vielleicht können Kollegen
noch fragen, wenn Sie Fragen haben, wenn noch was fehlt.
Konnten Sie in den letzten 12 Stunden Luft ablassen?
Etwas.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine geschwollene Bauch?
Sag man oder wie fragt man das?
Also ich habe den Eindruck, mein Bauch ist etwas dicker,
dicker als sonst, ja etwas dicker.
Ja, auch empfindlich.
Okay.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Mir fehlt noch eine Frage ein, die man stellen müsste.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Ich habe aber nicht gemessen, aber ich kenne mich aus mit Fieber.
Das weiß ich, ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass ich Fieber habe.
Man könnte sonst vielleicht noch fragen, hatten Sie in letzter Zeit
Veränderungen im Stuhlgang bemerkt?
Es gibt es ja manchmal, dass Patienten sagen, der Stuhlgang ist
dünner geworden oder schleimig oder so etwas.
Nein, da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Also beim Stuhlgang, bis gestern hatte ich regelmäßig
ein bis zweimal Stuhlgang, eher zweimal pro Tag.
Aber jetzt, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich gar keinen Stuhlgang.
Mir hat Patienten voroperiert, an der Blinddarm-Operation
und die andere Operation war ja die Oberschenkelfraktur
mittels eines Nagels oder Osteosynthese, kann man sagen.
Könnte man hier auch die Ernährung fragen, ob der Patient
so etwas Ballaststoff weniger gegessen hat?
Man kann ihn fragen, wie ernähren Sie sich?
Ja, ich ernähre mich nicht immer so gut.
Als Taxifahrer mache ich gerne einen kurzen Stopp
an einer Imbiss-Bude, dann esse ich mal schnell auch
eine Currywurst oder Pompfritt.
Meine Frau sagt immer, das ist keine gute Ernährung.
Zu Hause bekomme ich viel Gemüse, aber wenn ich eine
Taxishicht habe, dann esse ich auch nicht gesund.
Wenn Sie so weit sind, dann kann ich die Rollen tauschen.
Dann werde ich vom Patient zum Oberarzt
und Sie versuchen, mal den Patienten vorzustellen.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie seit?
Ja.
Der Patient stellte sich seit 12 Stunden
rechtsseitiger und mittiger,
wellenförmiger, plötsch aufgetretener
Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Der Patient hat 2 Mal erbrochen
und er habe auch Neuse und
Erweckenswert.
Er klagt über eine Neuse oder eine Neuse
und 2 Mal eine Erweckenswert.
Erweckenswert ist, dass der Patient
rechtsseitiger in die Generalherne habe
und seitdem der Patient Schmerzen habe,
er hat keinen Stuhlgang.
Können Sie mir kurz sagen,
wie heißt der Patient und wie alt ist der Patient?
Ich habe vergessen.
Der Patient Alexander Baumann,
er ist 63 Jahre alt, 1,79 m groß
und wiegt 83 kg.
Sehr gut.
Das ist wichtig.
Der Baumann klagt seit 12 Stunden
über plötsch aufgetretene Abdominalschmerzen
vorwiegend im mittel- und rechten Unterbauch.
Der Intensistenz wurde im Ruhe mit 5 bis 7 von 10
auf den Schmerzkala bewertet.
Er hat auch Neutri an bis 2 Mal pro Nacht
und normalerweise schlafe er gut,
aber seit er Schmerzen habe, schlafe er nicht gut.
Sie sagen, er hat 1-2 Mal Neutri pro Nacht.
Wie ist das mit dem Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise 2 Mal pro Tag Stuhlgang,
aber seit 12 Stunden habe er keinen.
Das Erbrochene,
Sie berichten mit 2 Mal GMS,
kann der Patient beschreiben, wie das Erbrochene aussah?
Das Erbrochene war schleimig westlich.
Ohne Blut.
Ja, ohne Blut.
Keine Medikine.
Sie haben gesagt, der Patient besteht auch eine Ingrinahlherne.
Laut Ihres Bürologen
habe er rechtzeitig ingrinale Herne.
Der Urologer hat bei der letzten urologischen Untersuchung
eine Weicheleiste.
Normalerweise ist das die Vorstufe zu einem leisten Bruch,
zu einer Ingrinahlherne.
Aber der Urologer hat gesagt, man muss das beobachten.
Eventuell muss man das operieren.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten bei den Patienten
in der Vorgeschichte, der chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, er hat seit dem Jahr Arteriella-Hypertonin.
Er nimmt bis zur Präzise 5 mg,
1 Tablette morgens und abends halbe Tablette.
Er nimmt 5 mg, 2 Mal morgens und abends.
Er hat auch Hyper-Uikemi.
Vor 2 Jahren hatte er 2 Mal Anfall podagra.
Er hatte 2 Malige Arthritis-Urik,
eine giftbedingte Gelenkentzündung
und im Sinne einer oder als podagra
Großzehngelenk, Grundgelenkentzündung.
Deswegen nehme er einen Alloporinol 2 Mal pro Tag.
Einmal pro Tag.
Und welche Stärke?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Eine Alloporinol 300, einmal morgens.
Gut, gibt es Operationen bei den Patienten?
Er wurde mit 10 Jahren appendektumiert
und mit 25 Jahren wurde er wegen Femofraktur operiert.
Welche Seite?
Rechts.
Femofraktur rechts.
Im Alter von 25 Jahren erfolgte eine Osteosynthese.
Okay, gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familie?
Ja, in der Familie, der Vater,
wegen der Herzinsuffizie, mit 88 Jahren.
Mit 82 Jahren, ja, mit 82 Jahren
ist der Vater an Myokat,
mit so viel Herzinsuffizie, zu verstorben.
Die Mutter, wegen der Krebs,
mit 59 Jahren operiert wurde?
Ja, wegen Kolonkarcinom operiert.
Die Mutter wurde im Alter von 59 Jahren
an einem Kolonkarcinom operiert.
Und sie...
Sie lebt noch?
Ja, sie lebt noch.
Sie ist verstorben mit 84 Jahren.
Die Mutter lebt noch an Asthma-Brontiale
und auch an Herzinsuffizienz.
Okay, gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, er habe auch einen Bruder, 26 Jahre alt
und er wurde Kolonkarcinom vor 2 Jahren operiert.
Ja, okay.
Gut, ja.
Jetzt haben wir die großen Ankerpunkte,
akuter Abdominalschmerz im Mittel- und vorwiegend rechten
Abbauch seit ungefähr 12 Stunden,
wellenförmig,
Intensität 5 bis 7.
Es besteht seit dieser Zeit kein Stuhlgang.
Der Patient hat kein Fieber.
Er klagt über Nausea und 2-malige Emesis.
Das Erbrochene ist nicht blutig,
schleimiggeblich, wässrig, aber nicht blutig.
Gut, chronische Erkrankungen,
atielle Hypatonie sowie Hyper-Urichemie
und Voroperationen, eine Bauchoperation, eine Blinddarm,
eine Apendektomie im Alter von 10 Jahren
und sonst eine Osteosynthese am rechten Oberschenkel
wegen Femofraktor im Alter von 25 Jahren.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ja, die anamlisischen Angaben
sind am ersten auf eine inkarstrierte
rechtsseitige Inguinalherrung hin.
Okay.
Ja, er wurde apendektomiert,
deswegen hab ich nicht ein Apendizitis denken,
aber er kann auch die Vertikulitis sein.
Es kann auch die Vertikulitis sein
und vielleicht ein Urulitis
oder ein stenoisierender Darmprozess sein.
Ja, ich denke, ja.
Ich denke, theoretisch, ja, wobei der Patient
das Gewicht ist konstant.
Er hat zumindest keine Auffälligkeiten,
wo er im Stuhlverhalten Richtung vermehrt schleim
oder blut beobachtet.
Der Uruloge fand eine weiche Leiste
als Vorstuf eventuell einer Inguinalherrnir.
Aber ich stimme da Ihrer Verdachtdiagnose zu.
Es ist wahrscheinlich der Verdacht
auf eine inkarstrierte Inguinalherrnir.
Sie werden den Patienten ja körperlich untersuchen
und dann kann man das vielleicht schon besser
eingrenzen und lokalisieren.
Ja, ich würde dem zustimmen
und man muss natürlich jetzt bei dem Verdacht
einer inkarstrierten Herrnir
nicht viel Zeit verlieren.
Man sollte, wenn dann den Patienten
dementsprechend dringlich operieren,
damit der befallene Darmabschnitt
jetzt nicht mehr kritisch wird, was ja sonst schnell mal passiert.
Okay, ja, vielen Dank.
Das haben Sie, denke ich, gut gemacht,
auch wenn Sie zwischendurch mal 2-3 Begriffe,
die Sie ja kennen, nicht gebracht haben,
denken Sie daran, bei der Vorstellung
den Namen des Patienten zu nennen.
Das ist persönlicher und das Alter
und kurz größe und Gewicht, sagen,
dann weiß in diesem Falle der Oberarzt
schnell Bescheid, das Alter, er ist norbengewichtig
oder leicht übergewichtig.
Das sind wichtige, wichtige Basisangaben.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ja auch für Sie selbst wichtig.
Aber ich habe Sie gut verstanden
und Sie haben die allermeisten Begriffe
auch gut übersetzt und in Fachsprache übersetzt.
Der Begriff der inkarstrierten Inguinal-Herrnir
ist nicht immer selbstverständlich,
aber auch das haben Sie gut hingekriegt.
Haben Sie irgendwann bald Prüfung?
Ja, 4. Juli.
Ja, 5 Wochen.
Ja, gut.
Wo machen Sie die Prüfung?
In Bayern.
Bayern ist groß.
In München.
Alles klar.
Ja, gut.
Es war gut und bedanke mich bei den Kollegen
dass es gewünscht und wichtig ist.
Ich hatte glaube ich schon mal gesagt,
dem...